en dépit de l'annoncé malheureuse du
décès des deux membres d'équipage du
mirage 2000 d de nombreux renforts ont
continué d'affluer sur le site toute la
journée
300 hommes au total dont 150 militaires
de l'armée de l'air arrivé sur place en
bus tôt dans la matinée les recherches
sont également assurées par 150
gendarmes et notamment par la section de
recherches de la gendarmerie de l'air
une section qui collabore étroitement
avec le bureau enquêtes accidents d'état
chargé de l'enquêté technique
pour l'aspect judiciaire cet autre chose
vous avez une enquête judiciaire qui est
diligentée par le parquet spécialisé en
affaires militaires
dans le cas présent et vous avez une
enquête technique fait par le bureau
enquêtes accidents et donc ces deux
enquêtes se complètent
l'una pour une pour mieux pour but de
réunir des éléments du nez potentielles
infractions judiciaire également
d'établir les responsabilités en matière
civile et puis d'autre part vous avez
une enquête technique pour établir les
causes de l'accident et pouvoir faire
progresser sur le plan aéronautique
le prg en tirant des leçons de cet
accident pour tenter de définir
précisément les circonstances de
l'accident
l'institut de recherche criminelle de la
gendarmerie est à l'oeuvre des
spécialistes des analyses post-mortem
médecin légiste dentiste ou encore des
experts en modélisation du terrain grâce
à ces sphères blanche qui sont en fait
des caméras laser ils numérisent la zone
de crash afin de la restituer le plus
fidèlement possible au parquet de metz
chargé du dossier
les recherches vont durer plusieurs
jours voire plusieurs semaines
les débris d'avion vont être placés sous
scellés est vraisemblablement utilisés
par la suite pour tenter une
reconstruction de l'avion qui aiderait à
définir les causes du crash
en attendant la zone est désormais
considérée comme une zone militaire à
part entière interdite à toute personne
non autorisée